the iPhone 11 Pro has been out for about
four months now
and it's clear that a lot of people are
happy with it even a lot of those who
are initially disappointed with the new
iPhone have now changed their minds and
a lot of Android users have actually
gained a newfound respect for this
year's iPhones so in this video I'm
gonna talk about what caused the iPhone
11 pro and pro max to gain so much
traction after people started getting
their hands on it and I'll also mention
my personal thoughts after using the
iPhone 11 Pro max for four months
including the features that matter the
most to me in a couple of
disappointments as well there's actually
one feature that it honestly didn't care
much for before I received my pro max
but quickly became the most important
feature hands down of the iPhone 11 Pro
I'll talk about that feature in a moment
but let's get into what makes this
year's Apple flagship so special first
off the most controversial change was
the design from the front you honestly
can't tell the difference between last
year's iPhone in the 11pro but the back
is where we got some huge changes the
biggest one is of course the new glass
square camera bump that's fitted with
three large camera bumps in an array
that's never been seen before on any
smartphone and even if you think it
looks ugly you've got to admit that it
stands out from the crowd if you see
this triple camera bump you know it's
the iPhone 11 Pro and honestly that's a
big reason why is doing so well I
personally love the design as soon as I
got my hands on it and saw it in person
to me it just looks very solid in
premium another change is the new matte
glass which after four months I'm
extremely happy about my previous iPhone
tennis max started developing micro
scratches on the back glass from regular
use and so far it seems like the matte
finish has actually been protecting my
11 Pro Max from those same scratches
which is very surprising I also thought
that the matte finish would make it feel
very slick in my hands and make it
easier to drop but thanks to the glossy
stainless steel frame I haven't dropped
it once this is actually the midnight
green color which is honestly the best
color I've had on any iPhone the green
tint is very subtle but it really helps
it stand out from the Space Gray so
whether you believe it or not the rear
of
new iPhone 11 Pro has actually helped
sell more of them because it looks and
feels different from other iPhones and
that's what matters to people now let's
talk about the internal features that I
believe have made the iPhone 11 pro so
successful the absolute most important
feature of all is the battery life Apple
did say that we get a couple more hours
of battery life with the 11pro but I
think the underestimated it I'm getting
so much more battery life now that I
don't know how is able to get through
the day with my previous iPhone 10's max
it's kind of ironic that we now get a
new 18 watt fast charger in the box
which I'll talk about in just a minute
because of honestly only using an every
other day now with my old iPhone I would
100% have to plug it in every single
night to make sure I would get through
the next day but now with the 11 Pro max
the battery seriously gets me well into
the next day and there have been many
occasions where it would last me two
full days if I turned on battery saving
mode towards the end of the second day
this was literally impossible on the 10s
Max and that iPhone did actually have
some pretty decent battery life and
that's why I think it's the most
important feature of the iPhone 11 Pro
it's the first iPhone ever that allows
you to do anything all day without
worrying about your battery life yes the
body itself did have to get a bit
thicker in a bit heavier to fit the
larger battery but the extra weight
really does make it feel more solid and
premium at least to me the second piece
of this battery life puzzle is the fast
charger and although I don't use it as
often it's actually super important now
that it charges so quickly like 50% in
only half an hour I know that I don't
have to be as careful with battery life
anymore
I can use my 11 pro for two days and get
it down to 5% battery life and simply
throw it on the fast charger for half an
hour and be good to go my old five watt
charger with the tennis max would charge
so slow that I'd basically only charge
it overnight so that forced me to be
very careful with my cell phone usage to
make sure the battery would last until
the end of the night with a new fast
charger all of that extra care is gone
and with the 11pro max I feel perfectly
comfortable going to bed with only 50%
battery life without having to plug it
in now before I mention a few
things that I'm a bit disappointed with
let me talk about two more features that
I think made the iPhone 11 pro succeed
the first one is performance which you
honestly don't notice much with regular
usage but it actually makes a huge
difference behind the scenes because the
performance of the 11pro is overkill
every single task including playing
high-end games and streaming video is
very easy for the processor to handle so
because of that it actually heats up a
lot less because it's using less watts
to get the job done and that ends up
giving us better efficiency and better
battery life my old tennis max would get
really hot while playing games and I'd
constantly have to check on the battery
life because it would drain so quickly
and now with the 11pro max it doesn't
get nearly as hot and I rarely have to
check the battery life the extra
performance also gives me a lot of peace
of mind knowing that it'll easily be
able to handle anything I throw at it
without any issues and there's one last
thing the awesome performance does that
not a lot of people realize it allows
for the best cameras on any smartphone
the 11pro is able to shoot 4k 60fps on
any of the 4 cameras including the
selfie cam which can also record 1080p
at 120 frames per second there is
literally no other phone on the market
that can record video this good at frame
rates this high and that's because they
don't have the same processor and sensor
performance as the 11pro something that
also really impressed me was the video
stabilization there was a massive
difference compared to the 10s Max and
you can see it in action if you check
out our iPhones head vs. 10s verse 11
pro camera comparison video the 11 Pro
has also done an excellent job in
photography as well with huge
improvements to smart HDR and the new
deep fusion mode which are heavily
processor dependent I personally notice
a huge difference in white balance
accuracy which was the main thing that I
complained about with my tennis max
now the 11pro might not take the best
photos out there but they're very
consistent which matters a lot to me and
combine it with the best video recording
out there I honestly think is the best
choice for overall camera performance so
those three things the battery life
there
or mints and the excellent camera
quality have been the most important
features to me since I got my hands on
the 11 Pro max four months ago some
honorable mentions would be the
difference in display brightness and
improvements in speaker quality even
though I didn't really noticed the color
accuracy or contrast improving on the
11pro I've definitely noticed that it
can get much brighter than the 10s max
viewing the screen is a lot easier while
out in the Sun and it's impressive that
it doesn't really get as hot as before
while maxing it out I'm also very
thankful to Apple that they've continued
to work on speaker quality and volume
every single year and it's much improved
with the 11pro especially thanks to the
new spatial audio feature which helps
stereo music and videos sound a lot more
balanced than before with that I also
want to get into the things that I'm a
bit disappointed about I'm glad we have
the fast charger this year but honestly
getting sick of the Lightning port
especially since Apple is moving more
and more devices over to us PC like
their Mac books and iPad pro I'm also a
bit disappointed with Apple for giving
us only 64 gigabytes of storage on a
flagship smartphone that costs over
$1000 it's simply not enough especially
since I'm racking up more and more
photos on iCloud while the iPhone 11 pro
is display is amazing I would have
really liked to see it get upgraded to a
high refresh rate display at least 90
Hertz instead of the same old 60 this
would help make it feel more snappy and
smooth seeing as Apple considers this a
pro iPhone it was disappointing to get
the same four gigabytes of RAM as the
cheaper iPhone 11 and even last year's
10s so hopefully the 20/20 iPhones get
at least 6 gigabytes the Apple watch
Series 5 has a new always-on display
which is a feature I've been wanting on
this iPhone for years and yet we still
don't have one and finally the biggest
thing I'm not happy about is the face ID
knotch it's been three years of updates
and we still have the exact same knotch
while a ton of other Android phones have
slimmed it down or even gotten rid of it
completely but even with all those
shortcomings a lot of people are loving
the iPhone 11 pro and it's honestly a
huge upgrade coming from the iPhones
head s-max
mostly for the massive battery life
difference alone so there you guys have
it those are
my thoughts on why the iPhone 11pro
succeeded and my personal experience
with my iPhone 11 Pro max after four
months if you enjoy this video go ahead
and click the circle above to subscribe
and check out our iPhone 10 vs 10 s
verse 11 pro camera comparison right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]